There you go right on the lens. Oh
We have a problem. We don't have a mic mountain. I will try to get a mic on this camera AsaP
I hate blood if jake ever asked me to do anything with blood again. [I] don't know if I can say yes
Now I'm taking the shit today
Oh yeah, I have not taken the shit today none of us have is there anyone else thinking about it?
Here with Brett and [nikko] and [Derrick], hi, all right?
We need everybody for this because what we're gonna do is we're gonna wrap Brett in duct tape why?
We need to put a fake head with an explosive on a body tomorrow on set so [that] the head explodes
well
You can't really do that on a real actor so what we're gonna do
Is we're gonna wrap them in duct tape and then cut them out of the duct tape which will hopefully?
Leave a perfectly formed human model will it work? What's that? What's that state if we don't succeed?
There's dignity because he'll be stripped nude after [anabaptist] the duct tape has been peeled off
Kind of out of the [close] like Danny and the clothes are going to hold most of the structure [oh]
Easy few nice fish. Oh yeah. Thank you jake we can thank you. You can clear frame now
All right, sir
Here we are at Morman Rock in Southern California. We got gavin from the slow mo guys in achievement hunter hello. Hello there
I'm Gavin done. We're the slow mo guys
God dammit. God dammit flew out last night. [I] did we had a super early call time 6:00 a.m.
This morning up first obstacle [6] a.m.
And our first obstacle [is] phantom has a peel melt and we only have yet ef lenses [canon] lenses yep
So we looked into finding adapter that it doesn't look like those exist this place is open and they do have a [pl] [mines] then
We should be fine
I'm going to assume that there's a rental
Requirement for insurance on this I'm going to assume that there's an option where they put an insane amount of hold on your credit card
so
Good morning
We have a problem just first thing we had to send brett up to get the lenses
He doesn't have any corridor information and his phone was dead
I gave him my phone because he didn't have a charger on him
Then I gave him Spencer's number because I knew spencer would be sitting next to me in the car
I gave him my credit card and my iD so that he could go to the rental house
So now he's getting a rental
with my credit card and my id at a rental house with my phone and he's calling spencer to talk to me, so
Carmichael's got a little much
we are
patient
outside of our location
Which is over there do this location is perfect?
And the dog runs at you
And then it cut our cuts to a shot of you of basically rock you coming around the corner with the bottle in his mouth
Running and you chasing after and you get the [yeah] yeah, so we can shoot a bounce fast you described. Yeah
So we only it will be done in ten minutes
How's the hike Spencer cuz I I don't know if you've ever met Gavin
But he's a very busy guy [we] only have access to him for a day you get a lot done in the day can
Snapshot go [Helen] right ren
we have a full video plan normally [it] something like this it would take two days to shoot but
We're gonna try to do in one [day] because [we] only have one day
Would you do to prepare yourself [to] be a volte survivor prepare for this role? Well?
I came out here a day early, and I burn the whole place down. [I] let see me. I had a flamethrower
[oh], oh, that's thanks. Man. I was really considered a
Really got me in character. It's like a destroyer of things and also ideal for the location
It's really really serendipitous that this fire came [through] here
I mean not for the people who were victims of the fire, but the fact that it left this in its wake
Perfect for this shoot well, it's pretty much perfect
You'll be about right here. You got your gun basically. It's along like a hunter's gun
You're not starving yet, but if you don't find food in the next 24 hours. Let's see you come up the hill with
Stop right [here], and when you get to right here
Sorry for any of the bad audio that may happen from this point on our mic mount for the red rope
So I had to put the btS mic onto the red. Mic mount broke like what do you want me to say?
It's alright, it's always a little janky when you switch lenses on a RED camera, out in the desert.
Three. Two. One. Action.
What's up Carmichael. How's it going man?
It's alright
Going good?
Looks nice, what is that? Rhode? Oh it's just duct tape on there.
Well, we have a-uhh 25 to 250 zoom lens
Do y'all know what were looking for?
I hope so I mean I hope I got the right lens.
Just don't break it, Carmichael, cause if you break its...yeah $10,500 bucks
I havent even looked at it yet so hopefully it's the right thing
[ON RADIO] Jake to raider, Jake to raider
There it is Carmichael
Its a really long lens
I can probably get this.
You sure?
Yeah, alrighty
What a swell guy
That's why we bring him ou- That's why we bring him around
Some soft sand?
Yeah it's some soft sand
Carmichael this isn't the time
Umm
Do we have any, like straps or anything?
Spencer, what exactly just happened?
I don't know exactly what happened, I wasn't driving.
Is this your personal car?
Yes Carmichael
It is.
It's kinda bottomed out.
I think, right now the car is scraping on the dirt.
[Kilis] [tonight], [okay], as you can [see] we got to collect that tune down there. That's valuable. Oh, yeah
fix uh
[fix] my screw gun
[Nadia's] got a more settlements
make more [sell] you know actually building those settlements was a lot of
filming it was the most fun dealing that and getting people to settle in there and shit [that]
[turns] into what the game is you're just building giant masses and campus
It's like they were there never ever actually satisfied like everyone all the time it was always like oh
We need more resources on I have everything connected
Yeah, everyone has what they need [ya] [know]
But I don't get about this shit does I say the post-apocalyptic world who dressed like this
That was reason got bermuda shorts in like Penny loafers man
That could happen I could have
you
I
Even know how [to] describe whatever everything is gone wrong with these blood bags. I hate blood disgusting
Yes
We came down this wash to get here for some reason when brad went to go get lunch he exited the wrong way
Drove up the wash rather than up the road. You'll see if we can get him out
Yeah, it's the one thing if your wheels start spinning
there
It is 7:30 p.m.
How long have you been up? [I've] been up since like 4:30 a.m.
[Alright] Ready 3 2 [1]
not even moving
He's got a phone [and] brett. What did the tow people the guy with the monster truck car Mike I said there's no trucks available
175 per hour
Just are you slowly brightening it? I just looked at the light. Why did I do that?
I guess it gets brighter when you actually look at it. Look what [I] need put these numbers oh
Yeah, this is yeah, this is off-road. Yeah, okay
[uh] well well we'll keep calling around then so you see like there's that big triangle there
Pointed to the last bars is good. Red one right? Yeah on the left the tip Saturn's the top right?
Damn, you caroline you brought this upon us
Good although the reason why I'm calling you is a bit of an inconvenience I
All righty yeah, no worries. I figured it was worth a [shot]
So yeah, I I mean, I don't I don't know
what to do right now [can't] find somebody
then
We fuck we go to plan B. Which is come back tomorrow [you] [have] to call
around tomorrow and find a way that someone can pick you up and bring you up here and
Pull the car out it's going to be super expensive
that's
Yeah, or derrick could drive you up, and then you can call a tow truck and have a meeting [here] actually that would be better
[alrighty] I think let's go make some room in the other cars
[I'm] just waiting on Derrick to confirm that but it looks like he'll be able to help you
Basically just wait on a tow truck. I think you'd be okay with a tow truck just they've gonna have they're Gonna need I
Mean if the driver is okay with it the driver should be the judge of their own. I don't say I'm hold
you